hi everyone welcome today almost one of
the last sessions i think
i hope everyone had a good lunch and
yeah recovered from last night as well
so today we're here to talk about
encryption and we're also here to talk
about machine learning
and detecting malware in encrypted
traffic using machine learning so those
are sort of the the topics that we will
be discussing uh today
so
before we start i wanted to make a small
statement
uh encryption is good for private
privacy however it gives challenges to
other aspects of security
contextual flow data is here to help
so um yeah even though
uh i very much value encryption and and
my privacy it also makes certain things
more difficult and throughout the
session today we'll have a closer look
at that
so i'm not sure if people were in
my session yesterday but then this slide
is uh the same i just copy pasted it but
who am i my name is christopher von
armada i'm half dutch half american but
i'm born and raised in the netherlands
and lived there my whole life
i currently live in rotterdam
i've studied in amsterdam did a couple
of
things on science park at the university
of amsterdam
all
are yeah very much
focused on programming and on
information sciences which is one of my
passions
i joined cisco straight after university
seven years ago
in a graduate program which they call uh
yeah where you become an associate
systems engineer
i then um
was a consulting
systems engineer focusing on security in
a northern european team so i uh yeah
basically
saw all kinds of different customers
help them build a security architecture
and help implement certain things uh and
uh yeah i helped them make
their environment safer
so i did that for four years and then
two years ago i joined the developer
relations program
in cisco or um also known as devnet and
i'm there in a role um as developer
advocates focusing also on security
so basically uh anything that has to do
with cisco uh automation
and
uh cisco's security portfolio that's
where i'm involved with
all right so enough about me let's have
a look at the agenda
quite bright bright slide here
i hope everyone's awake now
so first of all we're gonna do a quick
rundown of how encryption works uh i
assume most people will know it but i'm
going to
cover a couple of small things which are
important later in the session um and
yeah it's always nice to get a little
bit of a refresh uh on uh specific
protocols um we'll then have a look at
encryption and malware are their best
trends forever or not um then we'll just
uh we'll we'll dive a little bit more
into the actual topic um is and that is
basically how you can decide uh when
you're looking at encrypt encrypted
traffic which traffic is benign or safe
and which uh traffic is malicious or or
bad
um
we'll also go a little bit under the
hood of an open source project
um from cisco which everyone here could
use if they would like to
and
yeah we'll have a little bit of a look
how the uh how the the the project
actually works
all right so how does encryption work
again uh so this is gonna be in a 101
session
but very very briefly
when you take the the paint example
when you're doing a key exchange needed
for a secure channel later so you want
to get is you want to exchange a secure
key
to create a common secret which you can
use to start an encrypted channel
for example with tls
so very simply if you look at it this
way alice and bob want to talk to each
other they exchange their public keys
which is common paint
they will add their own secret color in
this case
and this will both turn into orange and
blue
now
they can then exchange the blue and the
orange over a public channel
because we can assume
that
separating this mixture is very
difficult and that's obviously when you
look at it crypto graphically it it
could take years to decipher um and uh
what the secret colors were
the nice thing is then if you add red
and bob adds blue to the mixture you
will get a common secret
cryptographically speaking so this is a
very simple way of explaining basically
what is happening
it helps me always quite a bit
uh when
i uh yeah i didn't focus on this for a
while and i need to refresh uh how
everything is working
so we're talking specifically to today
uh or we're focusing a little bit on tls
which is obviously used a lot around the
the internet and
in the web
so tls 1.2
we have a client hello
listing
a preferred
list of cipher suites in cypher suites
it's just a set of uh algorithms that
you can use to do
the encryption
then the server says hello back
and it will select a cypher suite it
will do key share and share the
certificates
then the client will do that as well and
then they're finished you can do your
get request or whatever you want to do
afterwards so this is how tls 1.2 works
in a nutshell obviously so there's a lot
of details
left out
but it's important here to know that
the client is sharing something server
sharing something back including the
certificate which we'll have a look at
later and uh yeah this is basically the
same as exchanging paint with tls 1.3 it
goes a lot quicker as you can see so
less error arrows means
more efficient less latency
you can see here that the client hello
already includes the keyshare
which is
different from before where the client
was just first saying hello
then the server
having that key can immediately start
encrypting parts of the server hello
which includes the
certificate
and then afterwards you can do the
secure channel
so this is
the difference uh between tls 1.2 and
1.3
and again
it's basically exchanging paint and the
paint is hard to um
to separate
now tls 1.3 obviously is becoming
the norm
and
but it does bring some challenges with
it
so
tls 1.3 because it immediately already
has the key from
the client hello
can start encrypting the parts of the
server hello so for example the common
name in the
which is sent from the server uh in the
certificate
is actually encrypted now
and that means if you're doing anything
on the network uh you and you want to do
any kind of enforcement with any kind of
gateway like a ips or a firewall or web
proxy or something
in there where you want to make
decisions on whether that traffic is
good or bad
you can't really decide anymore um
uh
based on the server hello
um what kind of track traffic it is what
is the destination because obviously the
big thing when you're looking at network
traffic is where is it going so when you
have a network of your organization
you want to know where where are these
connections being made to
and that's now more difficult to do
because we can only rely on the server
name indication and the server name
indication
just to go back is in the client hello
now the server name or
sni can be spoofed
because you can put anything you want in
there as long as you control the server
um
and uh
yeah
you can decide what to do
when you receive that sni
so what if we send a fake sni uh
why why would we do that for example
website a is not allowed so we're going
to send an sni that we're going to
website b
but we're still going to say say my p
address
now you could browse to a forbidden
gambling website maybe that's a little
bit boring uh but you could you you
could also have malware which is
connecting to a command and control
server to either
get an encryption key to start doing
ransomware or maybe to to leak sensitive
data so this is probably where where we
should be worried about so that's a
little bit less boring
so um yeah that that is uh what you can
do now
with tls 1.3
now there's also other protocols so we
have tls 1.3 here uh the usage is a
secure transport over the web
mainly
and then the goals obviously are a lower
latency it only uses modern cryptos so
if you if you look at a table with tls
1.0 1.1
up to 1.3 you'll see that only a few are
left
over in tls 1.3 which you can actually
offer
so it's a lot more secure and more
simple
and obviously it will have more you can
have more privacy um against isps or
governments or whatever
um you also have dough
not from simpsons but dns over https so
this basically means you're not doing a
dns request
in plain text to over port
53 but you're doing a dns request over
https as the name mentions
over port for for free
and the obvious goal here is to encrypt
your dns
lookup
and by doing that
you can't sniff the dns traffic or have
a look at the dns traffic if you're in
between
so this is also on the rise and most
browsers
support this already
then we have quick
invented i think by google
and this is used by chrome a lot
and yeah basically also is used for
secure transport over the web similarly
it has lower latency
it can also do multiplexing without
blocking so it uses multiple udp streams
instead of one single stream so there's
also some advantages there
now if we look at for example
combining a couple of these protocols
you can see that tls 1.3 and dns
normal dns you can see that
the tls 1.3 connection basically
bypasses everything so whatever you have
on your enterprise edge or your your
network edge your isp is not able to see
it
whereas with a dns request you usually
go first to the local dns server that
local dns server sees hey this is
public domain i need to request
the whatever you have configured there
so that usually goes to an isp
um
so
in this case we can still use dns to
find out where this person wants to go
now with doh it's becoming more
difficult if we were on the edge of
uh of a network we're not able to do
that anymore
so the only thing we can see now is
yeah the the the client hello again so
the server name indication
so here's an overview of that um of all
of the different combinations
but for today this is at least important
uh that the um
server certificate is uh encrypted
um and we'll see we'll have a look
mainly today at tls 1.3 but it yeah
basically goes for
more
and we see at the bottom one with
ech but that is not yet
a norm yet so that has only been
proposed
so this was a brief uh introduction on
how encryption works again i um yeah i
hope i didn't cover too much stuff that
you might already know but it's good to
set the stage
um important to take away
encryption is good it helps us stay
keep our data private uh but if you are
using network traffic to do security
then yeah obviously it poses some
challenges and it has been doing that
for years obviously
because it makes it more difficult to
know where the traffic is going to
so
if i were an attacker and creating
malware which protocol would i use
probably to
to
to make a connection uh outbound
well
what you see is that the tls 1.3 usage
is increasing uh
significantly overall by the way not
just malware but a lot of malware is
more and more using
tls 1.3 and supporting it
and so it isn't necessarily bad it's a
good thing i would say but
it does pose a problem when you are in
the middle and you want to make
decisions whether you want to um
yeah approve something or not
now man in the middle is yeah has been a
challenge for years as well already uh
due to privacy and legal issues
deploying it is difficult
it's expensive so you need a giant box
to do decryption
so yeah i i'm not a fan of decryption at
all
but i am a fan of stopping uh bad
traffic going uh to to command a control
server um and also more things obviously
so the lack of visibility uh
non-cooperating clients or cert pinning
uh all kinds of things which are are
problems for a man in the middle uh
decryption
so um
obviously it is a good thing as i
mentioned to get more privacy
so it can protect you depending on where
you live
from your isps or your governments
trying to
to yeah look into the data what you're
doing
i think everyone in the world should
have access to a private uh
channel um and yeah search for whatever
they want want and not have people
blocking certain things so this is a
good thing
always be aware by the way that
obviously you need to trust the service
wherever you're going to
because they can obviously see
everything
since the channel is
terminating there
now there's a couple of uh things you
can do with tls
so you can hide for example using the
main fronting
the main fronting you can see that the
same cdn has
multiple domains
and you can for example
do a dns request to example.com
do
your tls request with that server name
and you get it back but then you use
in the actual http request you use
something different as a host
this a lot a lot of cdns are blocking
this and looking for this
http this is goes against
the http protocol since the should match
but this is a way of of
doing some uh
yeah hiding yourself in this traffic
so here you see by the way um a
a graph
going up
and
often graphs going up are positive in
this case it's a graph
that shows a malware using 1.3 capable
clients the source here is threatgrid or
secure malware analytics which is a tool
from cisco to analyze malware and
yeah it also have as a big database a
fred intel that it
that it offers
so you can see that this is going up
and it's been only going up since then
here you can also see something else
which is domain faking so here you see
again what i mentioned you can put
something in the server name
and if you just
pretend that you are
capable of answering that
then you could technically
use that as well to
to fake where you're going to
if you're if you're a malware
what
what is seen though is that a lot of
malware
writers do use tls 1.3 but they
don't pay well attention into the cipher
suites that they're using so often you
can catch them there as well um
in in making mistakes that it's
for example an expired certificate that
they're using
all right so we covered now also
yeah basically the influence of
encryption on malware
so yeah that's obviously
important to take into consideration
that encryption is good but it's also
good for
malicious actors
so next
we'll talk about some things you can do
to
to look at encrypted traffic and to find
malware hiding in that encrypted traffic
without decrypting it obviously
so first off um all credits to two
colleagues of mine
blake and david mcgrew
blake has a phd in computer science
focusing on machine learning and david
mcgrew has a phd in physics focusing on
chaos theory um
very smart folks and they um
created an open source project which i'm
here to promote today
and they also wrote two very interesting
research
articles um so i heard someone say
earlier if you're having sleeping
problems then this
a really good
article to read
the first one is
identifying encrypted malware traffic
with contextual flow data um
very catchy um obviously but it's it's a
very interesting article uh on how you
can use
basically all the metadata that is uh
around there
for example like uh things that are in
the tls client hello or dns traffic and
how you can use that
to
enrich basically the information you
have
on that tls connection um
i can by the way uh post this the link
in the slack afterwards
to this article
they also wrote a new article as well um
and um this one is
focused a little bit more on tls
fingerprinting
um but it's yeah similar concept
using
more contextual data that is out there
to decide on where
um this connection is going to is it a
good connection is it a bad connection
if you simplify it
and again here they they look at
information
amongst others uh in the client hello
so the important thing here is that for
both of these articles they're basically
assuming
that the the server
certificate is not visible anymore
now they created a project called
mercury um and it's it's an oversourced
project as i uh mentioned
and it's basically a system that can
fuse together um yeah billions or how
many you have of real world tls sessions
and it grabs the information it needs
to
train a model so you can use this if you
have a big bucket of tls sessions you
can use this tool to train
a a model and that model you can use
later to
classify
uh tls sessions in either good bad and a
couple of other things which we'll have
a look at
so it is a um
a linux application but they do also
have a portable python application as
well um so all can be found on this link
but i'll share the links
at the end in the slack
yeah the challenge is if you're using
tls fingerprints
is that tls fingerprints are
very often the same
for a lot of processes so it doesn't
really help you that much
for example if you look at s channel
which is
the
i think the de facto windows
tls
module that you can use
a lot of different applications
use s channel and if you're just using
the default tls settings then the tls
fingerprint
and again the tls fingerprint includes a
couple of um
attributes from tls um yeah will be the
same so you can still not really use
this
to do a lot of smart decision making and
obviously if you're creating malware
then you probably also want to use
the the default settings for this
so it is actually important that if you
have actual destination context so where
is this going to for example is it going
to microsoft office.com is it going to
webex or
something like this
is very important on top of
just tls information to make your
decision on
um yeah so what did
david and blake do in creating this open
source project they thought of all right
so what if we
uh use different sets of information
fuse them together
and create a model
that can then decide
whether traffic is good or bad
so what they did is they used
the fingerprint from
the client hello packet
but they also used more network
information like
the the five tuple so basically the
source ip and port and also the
destination uh ip import as well as the
server name indication
so they had quite a few
um
things that they
were using and um and they can give this
as input to the system
and they would like an output
of a client process name so
what is the process that is
initiating this tls connection
um is it malware yes or no that's
probably something nice to get as output
and uh they also wanted the operating
system
so they uh this is something um that
they're currently using
and they're all taking most of this out
of the initial data packet or idp
and that is the client hello which is
unencrypted and includes a lot of
information and yeah you can you can as
i mentioned get a lot out of this
what is by the way quite interesting is
that you can also
see from what they're using if it's a
mobile or a desktop solution so browsers
tend to weigh more
use heavy
heavyweight algorithms whereas mobile
applications obviously
are more for performance and therefore
they prefer more efficient encryption so
that is already information that you can
get out of there
what they're also looking into and
they've already built uh as well
but they still need to implement that
into mercury
is the sequence of packet lengths and
time
the secret sequence of packet length and
time aka
spelt
splt um
is basically what it says so how many
packets are going um back and forth
as a function of time and what they were
noticing is
that malware behavior for example when
they're writing something to the disk
that means that there's no packets going
back and forth
so that is sort of the uh the length in
between whereas
communication with a command and control
server obviously is a specific pattern
and this pattern differs a lot from
normal browsing
so already based on this behavioral
information
you can also see have a lot of
good information
on whether something is good or bad so
they're still implementing this one they
did do it in a previous project which i
also have the link to as well if you're
interested
okay so this is their plan so how did
they actually
uh
yeah how did they do this
um so um yeah i did my best to explain
some of the magic
that they're doing they're using machine
learning um supervised machine learning
uh so basically they have it uh they
have used a giant database
uh or knowledge base
that both includes the input and the
output data of what they would like um
so it includes both
the the
the fingerprint etc but the information
is labeled so they know this traffic uh
is coming from this operating system
from this process and it is safe traffic
now if you have a giant database of
those kind of labeled sessions
which is um
um
yeah you can obviously also make
yourself
um
then you yeah you can start training
this model
uh so just a little bit more of
background on the machine learning so
basically uh yeah they're giving it
labels and data to create a classifier
and then later they're using data um
with that classifier to get the results
um
just a little bit of background
information and in in practice it looks
a little bit more like this
so
they have the labels and data going in
they're doing some curation
massaging and
it's then going to train it classifier
comes out of it but the results actually
feed back into the curation
so this is also what this system is
doing and they're still continuously
updating the model
so what did they then use so how do you
get
this information you could probably
think
so what they did is they
they have data from a anyconnect network
visibility module which is a
a a agent which you draw
which you run on
uh
on your macbook or whatever on on an
endpoint
and this will give basically all of the
information that is needed so it gives
the five tuple information about the
destination
it gives a timestamp it also gives the
name of the communicating process
it also gives the file hash
of the process executable which could be
malware technically but
this was the safe traffic so this was
usually a normal application
and it also gave the host
operating system
for the malicious traffic what they did
is they used fred grit which again is
that
malware analysis sandbox which i talked
about earlier
they use this
to
which is labeled because all everything
that comes out of a sandbox
gets a score of if it's malicious or not
and they chose
um
everything that has a score of 95 or
higher
to be positively labeled as malware
um
and they used um thousands of um tls
fingerprints out of this as well and
basically the same
information they just had to do a little
bit uh
of restructuring to to get it in the
same uh format obviously and there you
go they basically had one giant bucket
of safe traffic and one giant bucket of
malicious traffic um
and uh yeah that is what they used um in
as a knowledge base so here you can see
the amount of uh tls sessions uh on the
top uh so was 13
i always need to so we say milliard i
think that's billion in english
uh 13 billion
um
please correct me if i'm doing the
zeros wrong uh up to 53 million
um malware sessions so they have quite a
bit of sessions and they're actually
still feeding these sessions into the
system
and
every day they're still adding around 10
to 20
new unique tls fingerprints with the
information
that i just showed on the on the
previous slide
so the system was trained by fusing all
that data so the data came both from
an actual host
as well as from
the the wire so to speak so they had
networking data which they
fused with this host data
and
they match that together
in order
to make the decisions that we want
now what kind of machine learning
algorithm or statistical model that they
use you might ask
so for that they used a quite famous one
which is a derivative of the base
model so i'm not sure if people
know the uh the famous base model but
basically it says
the chance of a given b
equals the chance of b equals a times
chance of a divided by the chance of b
now we don't have to go into the detail
of the statistics here but this is just
how it works and basically the important
thing is that you're taking
certain
data into account when you're making a
decision
so
a given
b so you're not just calculating the
chance on a
now i have one fun experiment here um
what if there's an individual that has
been this so
has been described by a neighbor as
follows
steve is very shy and withdrawn
invariable helpful but very little
interest in people and
in the world of reality
a meek and tidy soul
he has need for order a structure and a
passion for detail
now is steve more likely to be a
librarian or a farmer
so who here says farmer
and who says
librarian yeah
so most people
in the audience said librarian here
which is makes sense to be honest i also
thought that at first
but and it's a very random example
uh it's from kenman and tversky
but they
invented or they basically discovered
that not a lot of people take all
of the contextual information into
account when they're making a decision
um what they didn't take into account
and by the way
this qr code i'll also share the the url
goes to quite a nice video um that
explains this
but basically no one takes into account
how many farmers are there in the world
and how many librarians
there's
so in this case there's they they said
that there's only a few librarians and
there's like
10 times as much farmers which is
probably true so what are the odds of
steve being a librarian or a farmer well
you probably need to take into account
how many farmers there are and how many
librarians so this just shows very
simply how contextual information can
help you make a better decision
and here you probably need to have a
look at what is the chance that the
library of a librarian given the
evidence of all the possibilities
and yeah you can take a look that for
example
40 percent of all librarians are
a little bit yeah as just described and
maybe
of the farmers are like that but still
since there's so many more farmers
there's 20 more
of people that are a little bit quiet
than uh then there are librarians so the
chance a lot higher um sorry for this
little side tour but uh that's uh in my
opinion quite interesting to understand
how this model is working
so this is the base model
the algorithm that blake
and andrew used is the weighted naive
bayes model
and basically what this allows you to do
is not just
use contextual information but you can
also give it weights
so this they use the two knowledge bases
which i described earlier
as training data
um
and um
and they wanted
to classify tls sessions based on two
features
the tls fingerprint and the destination
contacts so that's going to be the input
and the output
then are these three things the client
process name
the malware verdict and the operating
system
what they saw for example and that's why
it's important that this is a weighted
algorithm
is
that
the model actually performed a lot
better so they did some experiments
there if they gave a higher weight
to the server name and the iprs
to predict the process name for example
so the as you see here the the
destination context actually includes
multiple features and if they gave some
of those features more weight
then the model performed a lot better
and they can actually now predict with
like nine nine point
uh i think like couple of
uh nines uh with certainty uh the uh the
client process name without having this
information by the way right so they
just trained it using this data as
labels but now obviously the output
is that
and the input doesn't contain it
yeah so again the features here were
the fingerprint and the destination
context the destination context includes
the server name
indication
and they are classifying this and
with that we are nearing the conclusion
of of the session here today
so just as a recap
we saw how
a little bit how machine learning works
how statistics work and
specifically how important is to take
all
information into account when you're
making a decision
and when you look at the encryption a
lot of information is gone
so you need to become creative
into what information is available and
how you can then use that to find
malicious actors on your network
so to conclude
network encryption is increasingly
important it's helping us a lot to be
to be more private so that's a good
thing uh it is changing the way we do
data secure security it has already done
that so i think not a lot of uh
security teams are still doing
decryption um maybe in some cases you
can
uh for for maybe for inbound traffic but
especially outbound traffic is is quite
difficult to do decryption so i think we
should definitely
not even bring that up anymore
um especially because encryption has a
reason so why why decrypt it um so it's
changing the way we have to detect
malware on the wire obviously there's a
lot of solutions
you can detect malware on on a laptop
of course but in environments in
networks where you have a lot of iot
maybe
you can't place agents on all of those
iot devices so there's still a lot of
cases where you need to rely on network
data to uh to protect your network
and protect the hosts in your network
so encryption aware monitoring without
decryption
can enable us to identify a process
identify
malware
and at the same time still be
compliant
because we can what we can also see from
this
is hey are all of my hosts using the
correct uh tls versions here um
i think there's in the eu at least
there's these uh obviously these
financial regulations
where uh
i'm not sure if they upgraded it to tls
1.3 already but at least anything below
tls 1.2 is not allowed
so if any host of your on your network
is doing that it means you're not
compliant officially
so there is actually a production
implementation of this into a solution
uh from cisco as you can see here
it it will
look at all the connections
and it will see hey it is https
and we can
decide whether it's malware or not
and also we can decide what the process
name is and we'll give a confident score
on that based on uh that model that
we're using
and here you can see a couple of
uh of
of statistics here uh for example what
what the process name was
and uh
and yeah how high the malware confidence
was
and again the system is updating right
so this is a self-learning system that
keeps on updating itself so whenever
there's new applications being made or
new malware being made the system can
update itself and the model will then
hold all of those unique uh
unique combinations of information
with that we have reached the end of my
presentation here today
and i do have some more resources
for you
and again i'll post these in in the
slack channel so that uh yeah you can
reach them
yourself as well
and i would definitely have recommend
taking a look at this open source
project mercury um you can just uh have
a look at it download it and play around
with it
the thing is you do obviously need a way
of collecting those tls sessions
to feed into it um but yeah it's it's
yours for
for the taken and again read the
research article i'm not sure who here
is from norway or not but if you're
taking a flight home or train home by
the way then maybe uh check it out as
well
um here's some information how you can
reach me uh you can email me twitter me
send me a linkedin message or github
uh
yeah a pull request or whatever and um
and uh yeah with that i would like to
thank you very much for your time
[Applause]
could you say a few words on what kind
of classification models are being used
in this on what kind of classification
models like what kind of machine
learning what
basic algorithms
um yeah so um
yeah basically what they're doing um
again is uh using the weighted naive
bayesian algorithm which is an algorithm
which you can use
to to
give certain features that you're using
weight
and with that they can then
control how the output is is is better
so the classification is then more
accurate
so that is the algorithm which they're
using
it's called weighted naive bayesian
algorithm i don't know the the minor
details uh on it
but that's uh the
big picture of what they're doing
yes that's a good question so um
obviously that is a uh
a big um
uh
enemy of automation uh is false
positives so what they actually uh so if
in the research article they have an
overview of this
and
well they were obviously able to train
the model with a very low amount of
false positives almost zero
and then what they did afterwards is
they tested the model based on
traffic which was still labeled but they
didn't use in the training and i think
they
yeah i forgot the amount of
zeros
or
but they were able to reach a very
significant low amount of false
positives making this
an actual
system you can use in real life
yeah but it's a it's a really good
question
other questions
nope all right well thanks again and
yeah enjoy the rest of the conference
[Applause]